[Música]
[Aplausos]
valencia españa la ciudad de artes y las
ciencias
la obra maestra del arquitecto ingeniero
de renombre santiago cada trabajo
este edificio se construyó para tratar
de imitar el tan publicitado efecto
bilbao efecto que consiste en que con la
construcción de un edificio icónico con
arquitectura de vanguardia se logre la
internacionalización de una ciudad
logrando incrementar el número de
turistas a la misma impulsando la
economía y logrando una gran
regeneración urbana quienes de ustedes
aquí conocen esta gran obra
se ve exitosa verdad pero lo es no sólo
está costó cuatro veces su presupuesto
pasando de 300 millones de dólares a 1.2
billones de dólares sino hoy es un dolor
de cabeza para valencia mantenerla y
adicional a eso
se logró el tan esperado efecto de
incremento de turistas y no se dio a la
regeneración urbana inclusive hoy
valencia tiene demandada a santiago
calatrava como estas son decenas de
ciudades que han tratado de imitar el
efecto bilbao del guggenheim de frank
gehry tratando de lograr pero han
terminado con construcciones
costosísimas ciudades endeudadas y
después teniendo que mantener estos
elefantes blancos
inclusive guerri cuando fue entrevistado
si el efecto bilbao había sido por el
guggenheim contestó es mentira pero por
qué fallan estos grandes proyectos
porque tanto dinero invertido y tan
pobres los resultados se consultó a un
colectivo de ciudad se le preguntó a los
ciudadanos si querían estas obras se le
consultó a los empresarios
es viable pensar que fueron obras para
pocos obras para satisfacer los egos de
pocos pero volvamos a nuestra ciudad
barranquilla en el 2012 se me invitó a
participar en el proyecto recuperación
de parques de ella
los parques de barranquilla estaban
totalmente destrozados la organización
mundial de la salud recomienda que debe
haber entre 9 y 15 metros cuadrados de
espacio de parques por habitante en
barranquilla había
un metro cuadrado solamente pero en el
en el estado que estaban realmente había
cero
no sabía si aceptar el reto pues nunca
avn el sector público y adicional a eso
no tenía experiencia recuperación de
parques había gerenciado proyectos
grandísimos y había estructurados
proyectos de cientos de millones de
dólares pero que sabía yo de parques me
contaron en ese momento que en la ciudad
había un proyecto que se llamaba barrios
a la obra el proyecto era muy particular
se trataba de la pavimentación de nuevas
vías pero en esta los ciudadanos los
ciudadanos hacían colectas y hacían
rifas para aportar económicamente a las
obras así fuera muy poco
inclusive aportaban con trabajo
realmente me pareció interesante quienes
aquí han escuché del concepto de la
co-creación alcen las manos
para los que no he escuchado en la
co-creación es una estrategia bajo la
cual empresas o instituciones trabajan
en producir los productos juntos con los
clientes para sus aportes involucrarlos
y lograr el mejor producto o servicio
posible qué tal si los parques de
barranquilla los que creamos entre todos
qué tal si todos aportaban y de esta
manera mi deficiencia de conocimientos
sobre el tema la podía sufrir el resto
de la ciudad el primer reto de la
co-creación era la participación lograr
que la gente participara era bastante
complejo las primeras reuniones sólo
llevan alrededor de 10 o 15 personas con
el tiempo fuimos inspirando a los
ciudadanos de que era importante su
opinión sobre estos espacios por encima
de todos los parques son de la comunidad
recuerdo que en una de esas reuniones
después de cuatro horas de debate doce y
media de la noche me rodearon cinco
señoras a mostrarme en sus celulares a
sus hijas a ver si quería salir con
algunas de ellas no sabía que la
co-creación podía conseguir mi novia
el segundo reto luego de que la gente
participara era saber escuchar no
siempre lo que teníamos contemplado para
un espacio era lo que la comunidad
quería para él donde teníamos planteado
canchas de fútbol terminábamos
transformándolas por canchas de
baloncesto los ciudadanos empezaron a
aportar todo tipo de ideas iluminación
led para ahorrar energía andenes
perimetrales de trote canchas de fútbol
sintético
y juegos de niños juegos para niños
mejores huevos también que no que no que
no se oxidaron aquí en aquí en
barranquilla no le prohibían ir a un
parque porque podía terminar uno con un
teta no con los columpios oxidados
pero no todas las ideas eran innovadoras
genuinas y eso no era tan importante
como que gente participará en el proceso
he aquí el tercer principio clave de la
co-creación los ciudadanos debatían
entre sí peleaban hacían las paces
llegaban a pactos pero al final terminan
terminaban todos firmando los planos de
lo que querían para su park resultando
en el sentir colectivo que queríamos de
que todos sintieran que habían aportado
al mismo
cuarto principio clave de la co-creación
es la tolerancia no todas las ideas que
existían eran coherentes en el primer
parque que hicimos el parque sur y
salcedo en la primera reunión de
cocreación un individuo que todos
tildaban de locos sugirió hacer un
zoológico en el sur y salcedo la idea
era descabellada todos se rieron de él
pero fue la persona con la cual más
conversamos y luego de varias reuniones
lo convencimos de porque no se podía
hacer un zoológico en el sur y salcedo
además de que ya tenemos un show en
barranquilla pero esa persona cuando
aperturamos el parque era el que más
sentía subió el parque estaba feliz
contando a la gente de que había
participado en todas esas reuniones su
idea no se hizo realidad o si no
tuviéramos leones o serpientes ahí en
los juegos infantiles hoy pero pero es
importante tolerar en la co-creación es
importante tolerar a todas las ideas así
sean incoherentes y por último es
importante reconocer en la co-creación a
todos los que aportaron en el proceso
cuando apertura vamos un parque le damos
el micrófono a todos los que hayan
participado y empezaban a contarle a
todos los ciudadanos a 400 a 500
había sido con orgullo su participación
en la creación del espacio contagiando a
todos así de ese proceso de cocreación y
con el tiempo y con paciencia se fueron
transformando los parques de
barranquilla llegamos a consensos se
empezaron a crear estos grandes espacios
de los cuales ya tenemos 145 o 70% los
parques se han recuperado con este
proceso de creación
y hoy es un parque soy un son un total
éxito pero no lo digo yo según las
encuestas el 99% de los ciudadanos de
barranquilla consideran que hubo una
gestión favorable en parques claro se
estaban se estaban se estaban juzgando a
sí mismos ellos eran los que habían
participado ellas los día menos creados
este número es imposible solamente fue
posible por la co-creación adicional a
eso de generar algunos impactos que nos
pensábamos que iban a hacer en todos los
barrios donde hemos recuperado parques
11 por ciento más de las personas pagan
sus impuestos aportando así a una
cultura tributaria más equitativa
adicional a eso se generan 42% menos
justos en esos barrios aportando una
cultura más segura la calidad de vida de
los ciudadanos y su salud ha mejorado y
por último como los parques fueron
creados entre los ciudadanos y los
guardaparques que mantienen los parques
hoy tenemos los parques igual que el
primer día que los entregados
pero la co-creación
[Aplausos]
pero la co-creación fue más poderosa que
solo transformar lo físico y lo material
también se transformaron vidas en el
parque universal un parque en la murillo
enfrente del cementario universidad que
era horroroso cuando entramos había un
indigente que se llamaba en ricardo
cuesta ricardo puerto hacía sus
necesidades en el parque vivía y se la
pasaba prácticamente era destruyendo el
parque y aquí nos cuenta su testimonio
de cómo con la recuperación del parque
se transformó su vida
desde hace prácticamente cuatro años que
tuve una crisis en ella pues llegué a
ser habitante de calle esto me dio la
motivación para ser un testimonio de
vida
en la situación que estuve como
habitante de calle ya yo estaba dentro
del parque pero yo me servía de ahí allí
me bañaba lo utilizaba de pronto para
consumir las sustancias alucinógenas
pero cuando ya el parque donde yo estuve
permanentemente lo arreglaron lo dejaron
bien bonito lo transformaron yo vi esto
y me mandan como guardaparques de acá el
parque universal pues lógicamente que
eso para mí o sea va a ser sea bonito
porque porque voy a poner mi grano de
arena mantener los jardines o sea
hermoso diferente a lo que es lo que
hacía antes
aragón que destruir
tengo dos hijos un varón de 30 años y el
otro tiene 21
estuve separado por 10 años a través de
que el señor me dio una oportunidad de
vida regrese nuevamente a mi hogar
luego de la experiencia tan exitosa con
la co-creación empezamos a aplicar este
concepto en otros proyectos de la ciudad
tal es el caso del centro de eventos
puertas de oro cuando asumimos culminar
este gran proyecto solamente un 20% la
ciudad tenía conocimiento de él y su
imagen era sumamente favorable se había
demorado en iniciar su construcción
difícil o crear algo que ya había
iniciado pero qué tal si nos embarcamos
en crear su transformación y llevarlo un
buen término iniciamos con una campaña
que se llamaba por esta puerta entramos
todos y empezamos a llevar el proyecto a
la gente lo llevamos a los colegios a
los aeropuertos a todas partes inclusive
a jardines infantiles donde tal vez
nunca se enteraban de este tipo de
proyectos y luego de que ya habíamos
llevado el proyecto la gente empezamos
llegar a la gente al proyecto realizamos
más de 8.000 visitas de obras donde las
personas de que era sólo un lote
columnas losa podían visitar el proyecto
8.000 visitas tal vez hoy la obra más
visitada en la historia de colombia
y cuando la gente se iba el proyecto le
decíamos que por favor no dejará que se
soñaban qué iba a pasar en ese recinto
que querían ellos que pasar ahí
dejaron más de miles de sueños pero
luego de cuatro años de arduo trabajo
colectivo entre todos porque todos
participaron en este proyecto
solicitando que se volviera una realidad
empezamos a materializar esos sueños la
feria del libro la gran feria del
automóvil la feria gastronómica sabor
barranquilla
y el foro del microcrédito un foro donde
se pudiera mostrar a barranquilla como
una gran ciudad para invertir grandes
conciertos
y hoy puerta de oro luego de cuatro años
luego de dos años de operaciones un
proyecto con un 97 por ciento de imagen
favorable puerta de oro hoy ha aportado
más de 65 ferias y eventos y aporta más
de 60 mil millones de valor agregado a
la economía
adicional a eso logramos porque la gente
lo pidió tener un operador que tuviera
la experiencia para ello y hoy más de 48
barranquilleros se están formando en lo
que es el negocio de eventos y ferias el
conocimiento quedó también en la ciudad
adicional a eso es importante notar que
en el último evento
el foro de microcrédito el banco
interamericano de desarrollo llegaron
más de 1400 personas de fuera de
colombia barranquilla los hoteles 100%
llenos y además se empezó a fomentar el
turismo con la construcción del malecón
portador enfrente del recinto lo que
también está detonando hoy una gran
regeneración urbana de cara al río
magdalena nuestro puerta de oro no es un
elefante blanco he aquí el poder de la
co-creación
[Aplausos]
pero dado el éxito en el sector público
que estábamos viendo con la co-creación
decidí llevarlo al sector privado
quienes aquí conocemos han comprado algo
en la droguería julia
bueno droguería julián es una empresa de
mi familia una empresa de 108 años pero
es una empresa que estaba en la cuarta
generación
normalmente una empresa de familia en
cuarta generación está destinada al
fracaso el concepto era anticuado el
tráfico de clientes estaba en descenso
necesitaba una transformación urgente
así que nos embarcamos con los
principios de cocreación en darle un
cambio disruptivo de 180 grados
junto con los clientes junto con los
empleados los familiares y los
proveedores y luego
y luego de convertir ese concepto y
droguería julia bajo una tienda moderna
que está creciendo 400 por ciento sus
puntos de venta crece sus utilidades
anuales en más de un ciento por ciento
los clientes felices están generando
compras promedio por encima un 60 por
ciento de las anteriores los proveedores
han que han crecido sus negocios los
empleados están ganando más plata y la
familia que somos más de 60 estamos más
felices y unidos que nunca
la co-creación no es sencilla la
cooperación es compleja es retante y es
mucho más difícil que la creación
individual aquí repasamos los cuatro
principios que a mi experiencia son
claves para una co creación exitosa la
participación saber escuchar la
importancia del proceso sobre todas las
cosas la tolerancia y el reconocimiento
de todos los actores hoy los invito a
que se lancen a co crear en sus procesos
personales de emprendimiento o empresas
los resultados valen la pena es cliché
decir que hay coincidencias en la vida
pero hace este año me invitan a hacer
explicarte de c's 2018 y hace cuatro
años cuando le pedimos a los
barranquilleros que se soñaron que
creían que pasar en el portador o
alguien escribió esto
[Aplausos]